This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In March 2020, a few weeks after COVID-19 lockdowns began in the US, we asked listeners to send us voice memos about their experiences of the pandemic. We recently went back and listened to those messages, each one a tiny time capsule of life in a world under lockdown. Listeners told us about the stress of trying to find toilet paper and masks. They talked about the challenge of trying to work over Zoom. And more than anything, they grappled with the sudden, shocking ways in which their lives
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2020年3月，在美国开始实施新冠疫情封锁几周后，我们邀请听众发来语音便签，分享他们对这场大流行的经历。最近，我们回过头去听了这些留言，每一条都是一个置于封锁世界中的微型生活时间胶囊。听众们向我们讲述了搜寻卫生纸和口罩的压力，谈到了通过Zoom工作的挑战。最重要的是，他们艰难地面对着生活中突如其来的、令人震惊的转变
had become smaller and more isolated. I don't know if I could live with myself if I was stuck here and something were to happen to my grandma. And this is especially apparent when I found out that I could not visit my father in his independent living facility. My older sister gave birth to her son. We weren't able to be with her at the hospital, nor have we been able to see him. In those early days of the pandemic, so many of us found ourselves dreaming about what it would be like
生活变得更加狭窄和孤立。如果我被困在这里而我奶奶出了什么事，我不知道自己能否活下去。当我发现自己不能去探望住在独立生活社区的父亲时，这一点尤其明显。我的大姐生了一个男孩。我们没能去医院陪伴她，也没能去见过他。在疫情初期的那些日子里，我们中的许多人发现自己都在幻想
when we could once again hug friends and family outside our immediate household. We fantasized about the moment when we could enjoy going out to a restaurant or a music venue. We told ourselves that we would not take those moments for granted once we had them back. And indeed, the first time I got to see relatives overseas and enjoy dinner out with friends, it was truly amazing. The second time was pretty great as well. But after a while, that magical feeling inevitably started to fade, no matter how hard I tried
当我们再次能够拥抱直系亲属以外的朋友和家人时，那会是怎样的情景。我们幻想能重新享受去餐厅或音乐场所的快乐。我们告诉自己，一旦重新拥有这些时刻，绝不视为理所当然。事实上，当我第一次见到海外的亲戚并和朋友在外面享用晚餐时，感觉真的是太棒了。第二次的感觉也相当不错。但过了一段时间，这种神奇的感觉不可避免地开始褪色，无论我多么努力
to hold on to it. We see this in many dimensions of our lives. So many love stories end at the point at which great romantic quests are consummated. Stories that follow lovers past the wedding day into the years and decades of their marriages, those tend not to be romantic comedies. It's easy to be cynical and say that nothing lasts,
想要留住它。我们在生活的许多维度中都能看到这一点。许多爱情故事都在伟大的浪漫追求功成圆满时戛然而止。那些讲述恋人们走过婚礼之日、进入婚姻的岁月和数十年生活的故事，往往都不是浪漫喜剧。人们很容易变得愤世嫉俗，认为没有什么能持久，
that everything fades away. But this belies what actually happens in our minds as we experience triumphs and setbacks. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of habituation. How we get used to both the good and the bad in our lives, and the surprising implications it has for happiness. Think about the last time you saw one of your favorite desserts on a menu. Maybe it's the restaurant's signature chocolate cake. Your mouth waters as you read the description and you order a menu. Maybe it's the restaurant's signature chocolate cake. Your mouth waters as you read the description and you order a slice,
一切都会消逝。但这与我们在经历胜利和挫折时脑海中实际发生的事情相矛盾。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨习惯化的心理学。我们如何习惯生活中的好与坏，以及它对幸福产生的令人惊讶的影响。想想你上一次在菜单上看到你最喜欢的甜点之一时的情景。也许那是餐厅的招牌巧克力蛋糕。当你阅读描述时，你垂涎欲滴，于是你点了一份菜单。也许那是餐厅的招牌巧克力蛋糕。当你阅读描述时，你垂涎欲滴，于是你点了一片，
gleefully anticipating how good it will taste. The first bite does not disappoint. It's out of this world. As you continue to dig in, however, something funny happens. The cake no longer blows your mind. You lift your fork to your mouth a few more times, trying to recapture the magic of that first bite. But it's no use. What had been unbelievably delicious minutes earlier is now merely pleasant.
怀着对它美味口感的狂喜期待。第一口没有让人失望。简直是人间美味。然而，当你继续大快朵颐时，有趣的事情发生了。蛋糕不再让你感到惊艳。你把叉子送到嘴边好几次，试图重现第一口时的神奇感觉。但无济于事。几分钟前还好吃得难以置信的东西，现在仅仅是令人愉快而已。
What explains this? More importantly, what can we do to make the second half of that slice of cake taste as good as the first? These are questions that animate cognitive neuroscientist Tali Sharit at University College, London. Tali Sharit, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you.
如何解释这一点？更重要的是，我们能做些什么来让这片蛋糕的后半部分和前半部分一样美味呢？这些问题激发了伦敦大学学院认知神经科学家塔利·沙里特的兴趣。塔利·沙里特，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。
It's a pleasure to be back. Tali, you did some research in a resort in the Dominican Republic. Can you describe the setting for me and what questions you asked the people who were vacationing there? Yeah, so I was working with a big tourism company, and what they wanted to know is what makes people happy on vacation and when are they the happiest on vacation. So we did surveys and we actually went out to the resorts
很高兴再次来到这里。塔利，你在多米尼加共和国的一个度假村做了一些研究。能向我描述一下那里的环境，以及你向在那里度假的人们提出了什么问题吗？是的，当时我在跟一家大型旅游公司合作，他们想了解的是，什么能让人在度假时感到快乐，以及他们在度假的什么时间段最快乐。所以我们做了调查，并且真的去了度假村
and we talked to people, And when the data came in, we found two really interesting things. The first was that the holiday makers were the happiest 43 hours in. Why is that? Well, 43 hours allowed them time to get settled and unpacked so they could really concentrate on fun. But after that, happiness starts going down, right?
与人们交谈。当数据出来时，我们发现了两个非常有趣的事情。第一点是，度假者在度假43小时后最快乐。这是为什么呢？嗯，43小时让他们有时间安顿下来并打开行李，这样他们就可以真正专注于娱乐了。但在这之后，幸福感开始下降，对吧？
Less and less joy. Now, to be clear, they were always happy, happiness starts going down, right? Less and less joy. Now, to be clear, they were always happy. But on day eight, they weren't as happy as they were on day seven. Day seven, not as happy as day six, and so on and so forth. And the second thing that we found is that when we asked them what was the best part of the holiday, there was one word that they used more than any other word. and that word was first. The first view of the ocean, the first cocktail, the first sandcastle, the first dip in the pool.
快乐越来越少。现在，需要说明的是，他们一直都是快乐的，幸福感开始下降，对吧？快乐越来越少。现在，需要说明的是，他们一直都是快乐的。但到了第八天，他们没有第七天那么快乐了；第七天没有第六天那么快乐，以此类推。我们发现的第二个现象是，当我们问他们假期的哪一部分最好时，他们用的频率最高的一个词是“第一”。第一次看大海，第一杯鸡尾酒，第一个沙堡，第一次在泳池里畅游。
Firsts were exciting and new. The second dip in the pool was also good, but it wasn't as good as the first. And this is really, I think, a great example of habituation, right? When you see the ocean, it's wonderful. And the second time you see it, it's still wonderful, but it's not quite as wonderful as the first time. Things that are around us all the time, that are constant or that are frequent,
“第一次”总是令人兴奋而新鲜的。第二次在泳池里畅游也很不错，但不如第一次那么好。我认为这确实是习惯化一个极好的例子，对吧？当你看到大海时，它是美妙的。第二次看到它时，它依然美妙，但已经不如第一次那么美妙了。那些一直围绕在我们身边、恒定不变或频繁出现的事物，
we just respond less emotionally, and even perceptually, we respond to them less. So psychologists have found the same phenomenon happening not just among people eating dessert or going on vacation, but in relation to the most significant events of life, like getting married. What does the research show about happiness levels among newlyweds? Happiness actually goes up when people get married, on average, but then it starts going down and down and down and it reaches baseline level,
我们的情绪反应会变弱，甚至在感知上，我们的反应也会减少。因此，心理学家发现，这种现象不仅发生在人们吃甜点或度假时，而且与生活中最重大的事件（如结婚）有关。研究显示新婚夫妇的幸福感水平如何？结婚后，人们的幸福感实际上平均会上升，但随后它开始不断下降，最终回归到基线水平，
that is the level that before they got married, at about, in about two years. And also attraction to their partner goes down over the years. I mean, this is why so many Hollywood movies to their partner goes down over the years. I mean, this is why so many Hollywood movies end with the wedding or even the first kiss. Yes, yes, absolutely. But as we habituate, meaning we respond less
也就是他们结婚前的水平，大约在两年左右。而且多年来，对伴侣的吸引力也在下降。我的意思是，这就是为什么那么多好莱坞电影对伴侣的吸引力多年后会下降。我的意思是，这就是为什么那么多好莱坞电影以婚礼甚至初吻结束的原因。是的，是的，绝对如此。但随着我们习惯化，也就是我们对诸如海景之类的事物反应减弱，
to things like to the view of the ocean, we also respond less to our new love, right? What is around us constantly just doesn't really gather our attention as much, right? And we kind of, we don't attend to it, and so we don't really focus on it as much, and it doesn't really spark that kind of joy and excitement than it did at the beginning.
我们对新恋人的反应也会减弱，对吧？不断环绕在我们周围的事物就是不太能引起我们的注意了，对吧？我们某种程度上不再关注它，所以我们不会真正聚焦于它，它也无法像刚开始那样激发出那种快乐和兴奋。
So as I was reviewing this work, I could think of all kinds of things in my own life where I feel I have habituated to things. The same must be true for you, Tali. Can you tell me about some things that you have habituated to? Yeah, absolutely. Probably to almost everything, I would say.
因此，当我回顾这项工作时，我想到了自己生活中各种各样的事情，我觉得自己已经对它们习惯了。塔利，你身上肯定也是如此。你能跟我讲讲一些你已经习惯了的事物吗？是的，当然。我可以说，大概对几乎所有事情都习惯了。
You know, even my work, right? I mean, if you think about when you first got your first job entry-level position, it is really exciting and new, right? I mean, if you think about when you first got your first job entry level position, it is really exciting and new, right? But after a while, you kind of get used to it. And even if the job is your dream job, and it's really meaningful work, over the years, it doesn't seem that interesting. it doesn't seem that exciting. Tali experienced this acutely after buying the house she lives in. We moved into this house in the middle of the pandemic.
你知道的，甚至包括我的工作，对吧？我的意思是，如果你想想你刚得到第一份入门级职位的时候，它是真的让人兴奋和新鲜，对吧？我的意思是，如果你想想你刚得到第一份入门级职位的时候，它是真的让人兴奋和新鲜，对吧？但过了一段时间，你就会习惯它。即使这份工作是你的梦想工作，而且是非常有意义的工作，但多年下来，它似乎也没有那么有趣了，
So we have two kids and we were living in the city, in a place that was a little bit too small, I think for a family of four. But it was fine before the pandemic because we weren't in the home at all times. But of course then the pandemic started and so all of us are at home at all times. The kids are studying at home and so we moved to a much more spacious place outside of the city. And when I first moved, it felt just the perfect place to be. And it really brought me a lot of joy. Everyone had a room for themselves and also had a garden and there was trees and greenery. So
似乎也没有那么令人兴奋了。塔利在买下她现在住的房子后，对此有了深刻的体会。我们在大流行期间搬进了这所房子。所以我们有两个孩子，我们之前住在城里一个稍微有点小的地方，我想对一个四口之家来说是这样的。但在大流行之前这没问题，因为我们并不总是待在家里。但当然，大流行开始了，所以我们所有人都一直待在家裡。孩子们在家学习，于是我们搬到了城外一个宽敞得多地方。刚搬来的时候，感觉这里简直是完美的地方。它真的给我带来了很多快乐。每个人都有自己的房间，还有一个花园，有树木和绿化，所以
you look out of the big windows and you see all this green which makes you feel happy. And it still does but of course I got used to it and so the reaction is less and less and less. So we've talked about this phenomenon on hidden brain before. Psychologists sometimes call this the hedonic treadmill. For listeners who are unfamiliar with the term, can you explain what that is and also the links to this larger phenomenon you've been talking about called habituation? Yeah, so the hedonic treadmill is this idea that people have a baseline of happiness and you know some people could be a little bit happier than others.
你向外望去是大大的窗户，能看到满眼的绿色，这让你感到快乐。现在依然如此，但当然我习惯了，所以反应越来越少。我们以前在《隐藏的大脑》中讨论过这个现象。心理学家有时称之为“享乐适应”。对于不熟悉这个词的听众，你能解释一下那是什么，以及它与你一直在谈论的更广泛的习惯化现象有什么联系吗？是的，所以享乐适应是指这样一种观点：人们都有一个幸福的基线，你知道，有些人可能比其他人稍微快乐一点。
We can go do something that makes us happy, get married, get a nice job, but eventually we will kind of slowly, slowly go back to this baseline. Also, bad things happen to us. It could be really bad things. Lose a loved one, lose your job, and we would, of course course feel much worse when these things happen. But then eventually, slowly, slowly, slowly, we go back to our baseline. So that's basically the hedonic treadmill. But I think the phenomena that we're talking about, habituation, is it's related, right? But it's not quite the same. It is much, much broader.
我们可以去做一些让我们快乐的事情，比如结婚、找一份好工作，但最终我们会慢慢地、慢慢地回到这个基线。同样，不好的事情也会发生在我们身上。可能是非常糟糕的事情。失去了挚爱，失业，当这些事情发生时，我们当然会感觉糟糕得多。但随后，最终，慢慢地、慢慢地、慢慢地，我们会回到我们的基线。这基本上就是享乐适应。但我认为我们正在讨论的现象——习惯化，与之相关，对吧？但又不完全相同。它要广泛得多得多。
Habituation means that we just respond to anything that is around us, anything visual or smell. So for example, you go into a room and you really smell, let's say roses, right? Within about 20 minutes, you won't be able to perceive the smell of roses because your olfactory neurons will just not respond anymore. Or you hear the noise of the AC in the background and
习惯化意味着我们只是对身边的任何事物做出反应，任何视觉或气味。例如，你走进一个房间，确实闻到了玫瑰花的香味，对吧？在大约20分钟内，你将无法感知到玫瑰花的香味，因为你的嗅觉神经元将不再做出反应。或者你听到背景中空调的噪音，
it could be quite irritating at first, but very quickly you just don't notice it anymore. Right? So all these are perceptual examples, but our emotional reactions to things. It could be a dog barking. It's like the neighbor got a new dog and it's really scary, and we have a fear reaction, but the second time, less so, and the third time, less so. So there's perceptual habituation,
起初可能会觉得相当烦人，但很快你就再也注意不到了。对吧？所以这些都是感知的例子，但我们对事物的感情反应也是如此。可能是一只狗在叫。就像邻居家养了一只新狗，真的很吓人，我们会有恐惧的反应，但第二次就没那么强烈了，第三次就更弱了。所以存在感官习惯化，
there's emotional habituation, and it has a lot of implications beyond the hedonic treadmill to our personal life, but also to society. So why does this happen, Tali? Why is it that the brain habituates to things? At a fundamental level, it seems like it's a property of the brain. Why does this happen?
存在情感习惯化，除了享乐适应之外，它对我们的个人生活乃至社会都有很多影响。那么为什么会这样呢，塔利？为什么大脑会对事物产生习惯化？从根本的层面上看，这似乎是大脑的一种属性。为什么会这样？
Right. So there is an evolutionary advantage, right? The brain has limited resources, and so once we've processed something, then it's really time for the brain to keep the resources for the next thing that is coming our way. So imagine there's a dog and the dog is in the rose garden and the smell of roses really fills its nostrils. It is helpful that after a while, the olfactory neurons will just stop responding. So now we have all the resources needed for the dog
对。所以这具有进化的优势，对吧？大脑的资源是有限的，所以一旦我们处理了某件事，大脑确实需要保留资源来应对接下来迎面而来的下一件事。所以想象一下，有一只狗，这只狗在玫瑰园里，玫瑰的香味充满了它的鼻孔。过了一会儿，嗅觉神经元停止反应，这其实是有帮助的。这样一来，狗就拥有了所需的全部资源
to be able to smell a coyote that is coming its way. So we need to be prepared for these threats that are coming our way. So we need the resources, but also for the good things. Maybe there's a cookie somewhere in the distance that the dog should go and get. So that has an evolutionary advantage, but it also keeps us motivated.
以便能够闻到向它走来的土狼的气味。所以我们需要为这些即将来临的威胁做好准备。我们需要这些资源，对于美好的事物也是如此。也许远处的某个地方有一块饼干，狗应该去把它拿来。所以这具有进化的优势，但它也能保持我们的动力。
So if you think back to your entry-level job and you were super happy about it, imagine you stayed super happy forever. You will not be motivated to get to the next promotion, to get to the next job. You'll just stay where you are. So we need habituation in order to evolve as a person, but also as a society. And maybe
因此，如果你回想你的入门级工作，当时你对此超级高兴，想象一下你永远保持超级高兴。你就不会有动力去争取下一次晋升，去争取下一份工作。你就会一直停留在原地。因此，我们需要习惯化来作为一个人进化，也是作为一个社会进化。也许
the third important factor is well-being and mental health. So what has been shown is that people with mental health problems, for example, depression, tend to habituate slower. People with depression, when negative things happen, they don't bounce back as fast. There's a great study that was conducted by Professor Aaron Heller from the University of Miami where he asked students who just got a score on a really important test how they were feeling, and then 45 minutes later he asked them how they were feeling, and 45 minutes later how they were feeling, and did that for the rest of the day and the next day. And what he found is that those without a history of depression and those with history
第三个重要因素是福祉和心理健康。因此，研究表明，有心理健康问题的人（例如抑郁症）习惯化得更慢。患有抑郁症的人，当消极事情发生时，他们无法那么快地反弹。迈阿密大学的阿伦·海勒教授进行了一项非常出色的研究，他询问刚在一场非常重要的考试中获得成绩的学生他们感觉如何，然后在45分钟后询问他们感觉如何，再过45分钟又问他们感觉如何，并在当天剩下的时间和第二天继续这样做。他发现，那些没有抑郁史的人和有抑郁史的人
of depression, they all felt really bad at the beginning if they got a bad grade. But the difference was that those that did not have a history of depression, they after a few hours, they were back at baseline, right? They were doing their things, going out. But those with a history of depression or current depression, they tend to ruminate. They weren't able to go back to just their level of well-being that they were before, right? They were kind of stuck and habituated much, much slower. You say that in order to survive and reproduce,
抑郁症患者在刚拿到差成绩时，一开始都觉得非常糟糕。但不同之处在于，那些没有抑郁史的人，几个小时后就回到了基线状态，对吧？他们做着自己的事情，外出活动。但那些有抑郁症病史或当前患有抑郁症的人，往往会陷入反刍思维。他们无法回到之前的幸福水平，对吧？他们有点卡住了，习惯化得慢得多得多。你说为了生存和繁衍，
we need to prioritize what is new and different. So the sudden smell of smoke or a rustle in the bushes that could signal a lion or a predator, an attractive potential mate who passes by. You say to make the new and the unexpected stand out, your brain filters out the old and expected. So in some ways, this is really a fundamental property of the brain that's really been designed
我们需要优先关注新鲜和不同的事物。因此，突然闻到烟味，或者灌木丛中的沙沙声可能预示着狮子或掠食者，一个有吸引力的潜在伴侣从身旁走过。你说为了让新鲜和意想不到的事物脱颖而出，你的大脑会过滤掉陈旧和预料之中的事物。所以在某些方面，这确实是大脑的基本属性，是通过数百万年的进化设计出来的。
through millions of years of evolution. Yes, and habituation is something that we could see in all animals, whether it is a rodent or a dog or a fish. And in fact, we can see something very similar, what we call neural adaptation, in even bacteria. So this is something that goes way, way, way back and is really fundamental. I mean every neuron in our brain habituates. Our brains painstakingly construct models of what the world is like. When reality conforms
是的，习惯化是我们在所有动物身上都能看到的现象，无论是啮齿动物、狗还是鱼。事实上，我们甚至在细菌身上也能看到非常相似的现象，我们称之为神经适应。所以这是一个历时非常、非常、非常久远且非常基础的现象。也就是说，我们大脑中的每个神经元都会习惯化。我们的大脑煞费苦心地构建了世界面貌的模型。当现实符合
to that model, we don't react, or even notice it very much. When we come back, how to step off the hedonic treadmill and feel the goodness of good things again. Also, we'll explore the flip side of the hedonic treadmill, the way we habituate to things again. Also, we'll explore the flip side of the hedonic treadmill, the way we habituate to things that are scary, shady, and sad. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Tali Sharath is a cognitive neuroscientist at University College London. With Cass Sunstein, she's the author of Look Again, the power of noticing what was always there.
那个模型时，我们不会做出反应，甚至不会过多注意到它。当我们回来时，如何走下享乐适应的快车道，重新感受美好事物的妙处。此外，我们将探讨享乐适应的另一面，即我们如何再次习惯那些可怕的、阴暗的和悲伤的事物。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。塔利·沙拉特是伦敦大学学院的认知神经科学家。她与卡斯·桑斯坦合著了《再看一眼：注意到一直都在的事物的力量》。
Tali, you've told us how the process of habituation can diminish the pleasure and satisfaction that an event or an experience might once have given us. You say that there's a solution to this that you call dishabituation. What do you mean by the term? So dishabituation means starting to respond again to something that we stopped responding because it was around us all the time. So we start noticing it, feeling it, perceptually reacting to it, and if it's something good, the joy comes back.
塔利，你告诉我们习惯化过程如何会削弱一个事件或体验曾经带给我们的快乐和满足感。你说对此有一个解决方案，你称之为“去习惯化”。你这个词是什么意思？所以“去习惯化”意味着重新开始对某种我们停止做出反应的事物产生反应，因为过去它一直都在我们身边。所以我们开始注意到它、感受到它、在感知上对其做出反应，如果是一件好事，快乐就会回来。
If it's something bad, we feel the negative feelings again. Hmm. So, you once got a clue on how this habituation might work from a story told by the movie star Julia Roberts. Tell me that story. She was describing her daily life. How she wakes up in the morning and she makes breakfast for the kids. She drops them off at school.
如果是一件坏事，我们就会再次感受到负面情绪。嗯。所以，你曾从电影明星朱莉娅·罗伯茨讲述的一个故事中获得了关于这种去习惯化如何运作的线索。跟我讲讲那个故事。她当时在描述她的日常生活。她是如何在早晨醒来，为孩子们做早餐。她送他们去学校。
She comes back home. She maybe has lunch with her husband. She does some chores and then she picks them up from the school, makes dinner. And she says, if I was here for the last 18 years doing that all day, every day, it probably wouldn't still have pixie dust on it. But I go away and I miss it so much and I come back and it kind of sparkles. I mean that quote is great but the word sparkles is something that we really liked right? How do you just take the ordinary life and make it a sparkle? And what
她回到家。她可能和丈夫吃午饭。她做一些家务，然后去学校接他们放学，做晚饭。她说，如果我过去18年一直在这里日复一日地做这件事，它上面可能就不会依然带有魔法般的星光了。但我离开然后又非常想念它，当我回来时，它就仿佛闪闪发光。我的意思是，那句话很棒，但“闪闪发光”这个词是我们真的很喜欢的，对吧？你如何把平凡的生活变得闪闪发光？而
Julia is saying is well every time she goes away and then she comes back then she dishabituates right because habituation is something that happens when things are always there something constant something frequent but if you are not in that situation if you go away then when you come back then you feel it again and if it's good then it will respond to. So in some ways, the going away is an essential component of the coming back with joy. Yeah, indeed. And in fact, after we wrote the book, and you know,, I actually heard this podcast with Jodie Foster and she talks about how she was away on set filming for six months and then she got back home. And this is what she said, she said, I came back from somewhere that is amazing and beautiful, but you know, you long
朱莉娅所说的是，每次她离开然后又回来，她就会去习惯化，对吧？因为习惯化是当事物总是在那里、某种恒定的、频繁的事物时发生的事情，但如果你不在那种情况下，如果你离开，然后当你回来时，你就会再次感受到它，如果是好事，你就会对它做出反应。所以在某种程度上，离开是带着喜悦回归的一个必不可少的组成部分。是的，确实如此。事实上，在我们写完这本书之后，你知道的，我实际上听了朱迪·福斯特的这个播客，她谈到她如何在片场离开拍摄了六个月然后回到家里。这就是她所说的，她说，我从一个令人惊叹和美丽的地方回来，但你知道的，你渴望
for really dumb things that you're just used to that six months ago, I'm sure I was bored by it, but right now I'm like, my God, avocados are amazing, or I'm so glad I get to go to the gym again. Things that six months ago were sort of what I was trying to escape from. Now everything is amazing. I mean, I can tell you that when I go away for a long time and I come back, I just have this joy.
那些你只是习惯了的、真的很傻的事情，六个月前，我确信我对它感到厌烦，但现在我觉得，天哪，牛油果太棒了，或者我很高兴我又能去健身房了。这些东西在六个月前正是我想逃离的。现在一切都太棒了。我的意思是，我可以告诉你，当我离开很长时间然后回来时，我就会有这种喜悦。
My bed is like amazing. And then, you know, the view from the window is amazing. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] Now you might not be a Hollywood star who goes away for months on end to shoot movies in glamorous locations. That's okay. You can get the ordinary things in your life
我的床简直太棒了。然后，你知道，窗外的风景太棒了。现在你可能不是那种为了拍电影而离家数月前往迷人地点的超级巨星。没关系。你可以让你生活中的平凡事物
to re-sparkle just by getting up and going for a walk, or even wandering into the next room. So, I mean, there's all levels of habituation, right? If I'm now sitting in one room, I'm going to move to the kitchen, what I see, what I smell is all going to be different. It means I'm going to have different information coming into my brain, but also my brain will be all set up for change. So it's been shown that if you change your environment, even these small changes, you sit in the office and then you get up and you just go for a walk or you work in a coffee
重新闪闪发光，只需起身去散步，或者甚至溜达到隔壁房间。所以，我的意思是，存在各个层面的习惯化，对吧？如果我现在坐在这个房间里，我要搬到厨房，我看到的、我闻到的都会有所不同。这意味着我会有不同的信息进入我的大脑，而且我的大脑也会为改变做好准备。所以已经证明，如果你改变你的环境，哪怕是这些微小的改变，你坐在办公室里，然后你站起来去散步，或者你在咖啡
shop, any one of those changes enhances your creativity. Now granted, the studies show that the effect lasts for about six minutes. Every time you change, it lasts only for about six minutes on average, which is small. But however, many times that's all the amount that you need to find that the solution that you are thinking of or that new idea that is going to change, you know, what you're doing. I mean, I definitely have examples of that happening. If I think I can really remember every time that I had an idea that would change the course of my research and would be very important for what I do for many years to come. And in every single incident, I was not in front of my computer working.
店工作，任何这些改变都能增强你的创造力。当然，研究表明这种效果持续大约六分钟。每次改变平均只持续大约六分钟左右，这很短。然而，很多时候，这已经足够让你找到你正在思考的解决方案，或者那个将改变你所做事情的新主意。我的意思是，我绝对有这方面发生的例子。如果我想的话，我真的能记住每一次我产生了一个将改变我的研究方向、对我多年来所做工作非常重要的想法。而且在每一个事件中，我都不是在电脑前工作的。
Right. So, one example is I was not in front of my computer working. Right. So one example is, um, I was in my office, I was trying to solve this problem. We had this data and we couldn't make sense of it. Why is it happening? Couldn't solve it. And I said, okay, I'm going to go to the gym, left the office, started walking towards the gym. I didn't even get to the gym. And, and I, the solution just came to me.
对。所以，其中一个例子是，我当时不在电脑前工作。所以，其中一个例子是，嗯，我在办公室里，我试图解决这个问题。我们有这些数据，但我们无法理解它们。为什么会这样？无法解决。我说，好吧，我要去健身房，离开办公室，开始走向健身房。我甚至还没到健身房，解决方案就自然而然地浮现在我脑海里。
Um, another example is, um, I was again in my office working, but then I decided to have a little break. And I opened up the New York Times science section and I read about a study in monkeys, about how monkeys really enjoy getting information. Even if the information they can't use for any reason altogether, they really like it. And the dopamine neurons, dopamine is important for our reward system, they are activated when the monkey gets information. And the monkeys like it so much, they're even willing to give up some of their water in order to get more information. And so I thought that was really interesting. and that will eventually trigger research that I did on humans on the value of information.
另一个例子是，嗯，我当时又在办公室工作，但我决定休息一会儿。我打开了《纽约时报》的科学版块，读到了一项关于猴子的研究，关于猴子如何真的很喜欢获取信息。即使这些信息出于某种原因它们根本无法使用，它们也非常喜欢。而多巴胺神经元（多巴胺对我们的奖励系统很重要）在猴子获得信息时会被激活。猴子太喜欢了，甚至愿意放弃一些水来换取更多的信息。所以我觉得这真的很有趣。这最终触发了我后来对人类关于信息价值所做的研究。
We know that some pleasures lose their sparkle very quickly. We've all been excited about some new purchase only to see it gather dust in a corner before too long. But you say there are some experiences that retain the capacity to generate happiness over time. Explain the difference and what do you think is going on? So material goods, you can buy something and you can use it for years, right? Maybe it's a piece of clothing, maybe it's a TV, but probably
我们知道，有些快乐很快就会失去它们的光彩。我们都曾对某些新买的东西感到兴奋，结果没过多久，它就在角落里积满灰尘。但你说有些经历能够随着时间的推移保持产生快乐的能力。请解释一下其中的区别，你认为发生了什么？所以物质商品，你可以买一样东西并使用多年，对吧？也许是一件衣服，也许是一台电视，但可能
the joy that you get will just go down over time. Now here's the interesting thing when it comes to experiences. Maybe you went on vacation to Thailand, maybe you went to a concert, right? You saw Amy Winehouse before she died. And the reason that they tend to habituate slower is because they stay in your mind, right? So they come up in your mind when you recollect them, rather than kind of processing them in front of us. And so this was actually shown in a study that the rate of habituation for material goods is faster than the rate of habituation for experiences. So we're also slower to habituate to the pleasures of giving compared to the pleasures of receiving. Can you talk about this idea, Tali?
你获得的快乐会随着时间而减少。现在，说到经历，有趣的地方来了。也许你去泰国度假了，也许你去听了一场音乐会，对吧？你在艾米·怀恩豪斯去世前看过她的演出。它们往往习惯化较慢的原因是，它们留在了你的脑海里，对吧？所以当你回忆它们时，它们会浮现在你的脑海中，而不是像处理眼前的事物那样。事实上，一项研究表明，物质商品的习惯化速度比经历的习惯化速度要快。因此，与接受的快乐相比，我们对给予的快乐也习惯得更慢。你能谈谈这个想法吗，塔利？
Yeah, so there was a study that was conducted where in one condition they gave people five dollars and they said, take the $5 and buy whatever you want for yourself. You could buy a coffee, you could buy a pen. Day number two, $5. Buy whatever you like. Day number three, $5. And they did that for a few days.
是的，曾进行过这样一项研究：在一个条件下，他们给人们5美元，并对他们说：“拿着这5美元，为你自己买任何你想要的东西。你可以买一杯咖啡，你可以买一支笔。”第二天，又是5美元。“买任何你喜欢的东西。”第三天，又是5美元。他们这样做了几天。
And every time they asked the people, well, how much did you enjoy whatever you got with those $5? In another condition, they gave people again $5, but this time they said, buy something for someone else. So this time you're buying coffee for your colleague or you're buying a pen for your child, right? And every day they give them $5 and they would buy something for someone else and they ask them, how much did you enjoy this? How much, you know, how good did it make you feel? Now what's interesting in this study is they looked at the rates of habituation, right? In both cases, the $5 will give you less joy over the days,
每次他们都问这些人：“你有多喜欢用这5美元买到的东西？”在另一个条件下，他们再次给人们5美元，但这次他们说：“为别人买点东西。”所以这次你是为同事买咖啡，或者是为你的孩子买支笔，对吧？每天他们给他们5美元，让他们为别人买东西，并问他们：“你有多喜欢这个？这让你感觉有多好？”现在这项研究有趣的地方在于，他们观察了习惯化的速率，对吧？在这两种情况下，这5美元随着天数的增加带给你的快乐都会减少，
but the rate of habituation was much faster when you got things for yourself than when you got it for someone else. And I think perhaps the reason is that the joy that you get from giving is not just pure happiness. it is meaning as well. There's a meaningful act in giving to someone else. And while the feeling of meaning can also habituate, it probably habituates slower
但为你自己买东西时的习惯化速率，要比你为别人买东西时的习惯化速率快得多。我想原因也许是，你从给予中获得的快乐不仅是纯粹的幸福，也是意义。向他人给予包含着一种有意义的行为。虽然意义的感觉也会习惯化，但它习惯化的速度可能比
than just pure joy of drinking the coffee or using your sparkly pen. You said that another way we can thwart habituation is by seeking out opportunities to learn. Talk about this idea, how is curiosity and learning, how can they be engines or defenses against habituation? So when you ask people, what is a good life? What do you see as a good life? Usually people will say, I want to feel joy, right?
单纯喝咖啡或使用闪闪发光的笔所带来的纯粹快乐要慢。你说我们挫败习惯化的另一种方法是寻找学习的机会。谈谈这个想法，好奇心和学习如何能成为对抗习惯化的引擎或防御机制？所以当你问人们，什么是美好的生活？你认为的美好生活是什么？通常人们会说，我想感到快乐，对吧？
I don't want to feel sad. And they usually say, what I want meaning in my life. And then there's a third thing that tends to be an element of a good life, which people don't usually think about so much, which is variety. It turns out that variety is something that enhances people's psychological experiences, right? It gives you like a rich psychological experience and why is that helpful? And there's a few answers to this.
我不想感到悲伤。他们通常会说，我想要生活中有意义。然后还有第三个倾向于成为美好生活要素的东西，人们通常不会去多想，那就是——多样性。事实证明，多样性能增强人们的心理体验，对吧？它给你带来丰富的心理体验，为什么这很有帮助呢？这里有几个答案。
One is that variety means that we will habituate less to things because it's changing all the time, right? We're doing one thing, we're doing the other thing, right? So variety actually counters the effects of habituation. But the other reason is if you have variety in your life, you work on different projects, you talk to different types of people, you are in different places. It always involves learning.
一个是多样性意味着我们将对事物习惯得更少，因为一切都在一直变化，对吧？我们做这件事，又做另一件事，对吧？所以多样性实际上抵消了习惯化的影响。但另一个原因如果你生活中有多样性，你从事不同的项目，你和不同类型的人交谈，你身处不同的地方。这总是涉及学习。
And the thing about learning is, learning means that there is a change. You cannot habituate to change, by definition. Gaining knowledge is processed in the brain like food, like water, like sex. There's the response that we have when we are learning something new, which, you know, why do people enjoy podcasts so much, right? Because you're always learning, you're gaining knowledge, and your brain responds to that like it does to chocolate, but you don't get fat.
关于学习，有一点是，学习意味着发生了改变。根据定义，你无法对改变习惯化。获取知识在大脑中的处理方式就像食物、水、性一样。当我们学习新东西时，我们会有那种反应，你知道的，为什么人们那么喜欢播客，对吧？因为你一直在学习，你在获取知识，你的大脑对它的反应就像对巧克力一样，但你不会发胖。
So let's go back to the example of eating dessert or going on a vacation. Many of us assume that when it comes to pleasant or joyful experiences, it's best to enjoy these experiences without interruption. But from what you're saying in the last few minutes, I'm not sure that's true. Is it, Telly? Yeah, no, it's not. Because let's go back to the vacation example. The most, like happiest time was 43 hours in.
所以让我们回到吃甜点或度假的例子。我们许多人认为，当谈到愉快或快乐的体验时，最好是不间断地享受这些体验。但从你过去几分钟所说的话来看，我不确定这是真的。是这样吗，塔利？是的，不，不是的。因为让我们回到度假的例子。最快乐的时刻是在度假43小时的时候。
And the word that they use most to describe the best parts of the vacation was first, first, first, first. So then really what that means is that you want to create more firsts. You want to create more 43 hours in, right? So instead of going for a long two-week vacation somewhere, you might choose to go on shorter, maybe like a long weekend or, you know, maybe just a weekend. So take a few short vacations rather than the long one to get more of these exciting novel things. And there's empirical evidence to support this. So there is a great study where people
而他们用来描述假期中最美好部分的词汇最多的是“第一、第一、第一、第一”。所以这实际上意味着，你想要创造更多的“第一次”。你想要创造更多像“43小时”那样的时刻，对吧？所以，与其去某地进行漫长两周的度假，你可能会选择去较短的旅行，也许是一个长周末，或者，你知道的，也许只是一个周末。所以进行几次短假，而不是一次长假，以获得更多这些令人兴奋的新奇事物。有经验证据支持这一点。所以有一项非常棒的研究，人们
were asked, think about a song that you really like and What do you think would you enjoy it more if you listen to the song from beginning to end with no interruptions? Or if you had interruptions, so you listen to the song 20 seconds and a little interruption 20 seconds little interruption 99% of people said I want to hear the song from beginning to end. I do not want any interruptions, right? I mean, it seems obvious. But when they then did the test and they tested how much people enjoy the song with or without interruptions,
被问到：想想一首歌，你真的很喜欢它，你认为你会更享受以下哪种方式：从头到尾不间断地听这首歌？还是中间有中断，比如听这首歌20秒，然后一个小中断，再听20秒，又一个小中断？99%的人说我想从头到尾听这首歌。我不要任何中断，对吧？我的意思是，这似乎显而易见。但当他们随后进行测试并测试人们在有中断或没有中断的情况下有多喜欢这首歌时，
what they find is that people enjoy the song more if it was interrupted. And they were willing to pay twice as much to hear the song in concert, which is super counterintuitive. And they did the same study with massages. Do you want to have the massage from beginning to end, no interruptions? Or do you want to have it with breaks? People want it beginning to end, no interruptions, but in fact, enjoy it more if there are breaks. And there is an economist
他们发现人们更喜欢被打断的歌曲。而且他们愿意支付两倍的价钱去听音乐会在现场演奏，这超级反直觉。他们对按摩也做了同样的研究。你想从头到尾不间断地按摩吗？还是想中间有休息？人们想要从头到尾不间断的，但事实上，如果有休息的话会更享受。有一位经济学家
named Tipper Skutovsky who has a quote which really puts this in a great sentence, which he says, pleasure results from incomplete and intermittent satisfaction of desires. So break up the good experiences into bits to enjoy it more. In other words, when you order the chocolate cake at the restaurant, eat half a slice because that's the slice that's actually going to give you a lot of pleasure. Take the rest home and eat it at home an hour later and you'll enjoy the second half of the slice as much as the first compared to eating it all together in one go. Or even better, give the second side, we often do try to break up unpleasant experiences, so we don't have
名叫蒂珀·斯库托夫斯基（Tipper Skutovsky），他有一句名言很好地概括了这一点：“快乐源于对欲望的不完全和间歇性的满足。”把美好的体验拆成碎片来享受会更多。换句话说，当你在餐厅点巧克力蛋糕时，吃半片，因为那是真正能给你带来巨大快乐的一片。把剩下的带回家，一个小时后在家吃，你会和第一片一样享受后半部分，而不是一次性全部吃完。或者更好的是，把第二块……我们经常尝试分解不愉快的体验，这样我们就不必
to deal with all of it at once. So we say, I need to clean my bathroom, but maybe I'll do part of it on a Saturday and part of it on a Sunday. Is that a good idea or a terrible idea? For the bad stuff, you want to, we say, swallow the bad hole. So, for example, if you think about something that you don't like to do, maybe for me, it's like household chores or grading papers.
一次性应对所有这些。所以我们说，我需要打扫浴室，但也许我周六做一部分，周日做一部分。这是个好主意还是个糟糕的主意？对于糟糕的事情，你会想要……我们说，一口吞下苦果。例如，如果你想到某些你不喜欢做的事情，对批改试卷或我来说可能是家务活。
If I do maybe, like, 15 minutes in a break, 20 minutes in a break, what happens is that I'm breaking my habituation to the bat. So if you're doing like cleaning, for example, there's maybe like a bad smell of the cleaning products, but you habituate to it so you don't smell it anymore. And that's good. But if I then break it, I have a little break and I have a cup of coffee and then I go back and I start the chore again,
如果我做个15分钟左右然后休息，20分钟然后休息，发生的情况是我打破了我对糟糕事物的习惯化。所以如果你在打扫卫生，例如，清洁剂可能有一种难闻的气味，但你习惯了它，所以你闻不到了。这很好。但如果我随后打破它，我稍微休息一下，喝杯咖啡，然后我回去再次开始做家务，
well then I'm gonna feel, again, bad, right? I'm gonna like perceive the smell and all of that. And again, there's empirical data when they actually did the test with people listening to really annoying sounds and they found, yes, if you just get it over with, you don't rate it as bad, but if you kind of chop it into bits,
那么我就会再次感觉不好，对吧？我会感知到气味等等。同样，当他们对听着真正烦人声音的人进行测试时，确实有经验数据表明，是的，如果你只是把它做完，你不会觉得它那么糟把它切成碎片，
then you rate the experience as much worse. It's so interesting that our intuitions in both cases are exactly the opposite of what actually we should be doing. So we have a reluctance to break up pleasant experiences. We want to take them all in at once, and we do want to break up unpleasant experiences and not take them in at once.
那么你会把这种经历评为糟糕得多。非常有趣的是，我们在两种情况下的直觉都与我们实际应该做的完全相反。因此，我们不愿意打破愉快的经历。我们想一次性全部接受，而我们确实想打破不愉快的经历并不想一次性接受。
The advice actually in both situations is to do exactly the opposite. Yeah. You know, there are sayings about savoring or about like, oh, get it over and done with. But then in reality, it's really hard. It's hard to savor. If there's something good, we don't want to stop. It's really hard when we're doing something unpleasant not to take breaks. So I think the wisdom is there in the culture, but not necessarily something that we do practically. Even if the wisdom is difficult to follow, it may seem straightforward.
这两种情况下的建议实际上都是做完全相反的事情。是的。你知道的，有一些关于细细品味的名言，或者是关于“赶快把它做完”的名言。但在现实中，这真的很难。品味很难。如果有好事，我们不想停下来。当我们做不愉快的事情时，很难不休息。所以我认为这种智慧存在于文化中，但不一定是我们在实践中所做的事情。即使这种智慧很难遵循，它似乎也很简单。
Power through unpleasant tasks so you don't have to experience the unpleasantness anew by coming back to them multiple times. With your pleasant experiences, do the opposite. Break them up so that you can maximize the delight they give you. Seems simple, right? There's a catch, though. Not all unpleasant experiences are created equal. And in some cases, there's a very real cost
全力应对不愉快的任务，这样你就不用通过多次返回来重新体验那种不愉快。对于你的愉快的经历，做相反的事情。把它们拆开，这样你就能最大化它们带听觉的快乐。听起来很简单，对吧？然而，这里有个陷阱。并非所有不愉快的体验生来平等。在某些情况下，存在着非常真实的代价
that comes from numbing ourselves to their unpleasantness. When we come back, how our minds habituate to things like danger, dishonesty, and discrimination. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Across every domain of our lives, our minds have a tendency to get accustomed to things. In fact, the brain seems evolutionarily designed to focus on the new and unexpected, on novel threats and opportunities. In our daily lives, this means we take wonderful things for granted. We cease to appreciate amazing people in our lives or
它来自于我们对不愉快的事情变得麻木。当我们回来时，我们的大脑如何习惯危险、不诚实和歧视等事情。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在我们生活的每一个领域，我们的大脑都有习惯于事物的倾向。事实上，大脑在进化上似乎旨在专注于新鲜和意想不到的事物、新奇的威胁和机遇。在我们的日常生活中，这意味着我们把美好的事物视为理所当然。我们不再欣赏我们生活中的了不起的人，或者
the good fortune of being healthy. We become habituated to these gifts and stop noticing them. With Cass Sunstein, Tali Sharit is the co-author of the book, Look Again, The Power of Noticing What Was Always There. Tali, so far we've talked mostly about the ways we habituate to positive things, but of course the mind also habituates to negative things. In 1999, a huge public works project in Massachusetts was wrapping up. It had taken a decade to complete. All that remained was to open an underwater tunnel. I want to play you a public television news clip about what happened that day.
保持健康的幸运。我们对这些恩赐习以为常，不再去注意它们。与凯斯·桑斯坦一样，塔ali·沙里特也是《再看一眼：注意到一直都在的力量》一书的合著者。塔ali，到目前为止，我们主要讨论了我们对积极事物习惯化的方式，但当然，大脑也会对消极事物产生习惯化。1999年，马萨诸塞州的一个大型公共工程项目即将完工。这个项目花了十年时间才完成。剩下的唯一工作就是开通一条水下隧道。我想放一段关于那天发生事情的公共电视新闻剪辑给你听。
The tunnel burrowed into the bay's bedrock was devoid of light and oxygen, requiring the divers to carry a specialized breathing system. On a July morning, the five divers set out. Disaster struck when the breathing system malfunctioned. Three of the divers made it out alive, but two died. Thirty-three-year-old William Juice and 39-year-old Tim Nordean died of asphyxiation. Tali, tell me the story of this project and what it tells us about habituation. So there was a decade long Boston Harbor cleanup.
这条钻入海湾基岩的隧道没有光线和氧气，潜水员必须携带专门的呼吸系统。在一个七月的早晨，五名潜水员出发了。当呼吸系统发生故障时，灾难降临了。三名潜水员活着出来了，但有两人不幸身亡。33岁的威廉·朱斯和39岁的蒂姆·诺迪恩因窒息身亡。塔ali，请给我讲讲这个项目的故事，以及它对我们理解习惯化有什么启示。当时进行了长达十年的波士顿港清理工作。
So if you visit Boston today, there's clear blue waters, there's sailing boats around. But back in the day, apparently, it was quite dirty. It wasn't as nice. And so they had hundreds of workers working. It costs $4 billion to clean up the harbor. And it was high risk the whole time. But at the very end, they sent five divers into a tube hundreds of feet below the ocean floor to remove heavy safety plugs.
所以如果你今天参观波士顿，你会看到清澈蔚蓝的海水，周围有帆船在航行。但在过去，据说那里相当脏。没有现在这么好。当时有数百名工人参与其中。清理港口花费了40亿美元。而且整个过程风险很高。但在最后关头，他们派了五名潜水员进入海底数百英尺的一根管子里，去移除重型安全塞。
And the tunnel had no oxygen or light. And the narrowest part of it was only five feet in diameter. And the divers were to travel all the way to the far end of the 10-mile long tunnel. And then inside a series of pipes, there were only about 30 inches wide, so they became kind of smaller and smaller. And despite the project was pretty complex, the drivers trained for only two weeks and they relied on experimental breathing apparatus, right? So it doesn't seem that a lot of cautionary measures were taken. And unfortunately, the breathing system failed and only three of the five divers got back
而且这条隧道没有氧气也没有光线。最窄的部分直径只有五英尺。潜水员必须一直走到这根长达10英里的隧道的尽头。然后在一些直径只有约30英寸的管道内部穿行，这些管道变得越来越小。尽管这个项目相当复杂，但潜水员只接受了两个星期的训练，而且他们依赖的是实验性的呼吸装置，对吧？所以似乎并没有采取太多的防范措施。不幸的是，呼吸系统故障了，五名潜水员中只有三人回到了
to safety. And even those that got back to safety had only 30 seconds to spare. And so it actually is not unusual that disasters in, for example, these kind of construction projects, they tend to happen very late in the project, towards the very end. Because what seems to happen is that early on, people are very cautious, they're very risk averse, they take all the measures.
安全地带。即使是那些安全返回的人，也仅仅在最后30秒死里逃生。所以事实上，例如在这些建筑项目中，灾难往往发生在项目非常后期、接近尾声的时候，这并不罕见。因为似乎发生的情况是，在早期阶段，人们非常谨慎，非常厌恶风险，他们会采取所有的防范措施。
But then after time, they habituate to the risk. They don't have the emotional reaction, the anxiety and the fear. And that's when most of the accidents on construction sites tend to happen. So you've conducted research that examines the process of risk habituation using virtual reality. Tell me the setup of these studies, Tali. Right, so we wanted to put people in a really threatening position, something that really will kind of cause them fear. But of course, we can't put our participants in a place where they're really under physical risk. So we use the next best thing, which is virtual
但随着时间的推移，他们对风险习以为常了。他们不再有情绪反应、焦虑和恐惧。而这正是建筑工地上最容易发生事故的时候。那么，你曾利用虚拟现实技术开展过研究，来考察风险习惯化的过程。塔ali，能介绍一下这些研究的设置吗？好的，所以我们想把人们置于一个真正具有威胁性的环境中，一种真正能引起他们恐惧的情境。但当然，我们不能把参与者置于真正面临身体风险的地方。所以我们使用了次优的选择，也就是虚拟
reality. And we use this game in virtual reality where what you see is yourself going up an elevator, up a skyscraper, and then the elevator opens up and then you can walk on a plank that is basically far, far, far up, up, up, up, up, and you're looking down and it's really scary. Now, it absolutely tricks your brain to believe that I'm thousands of feet up walking on a plank and if I just tip, I'm going to fall and I'm going to die. It's amazing how that feels so real. And so what we had is we had our participants go up and they maybe took like one little step. We asked them, how are you feeling?
现实。我们在虚拟现实中使用了一个游戏，你看到自己坐着电梯上升，穿过一座摩天大楼，然后电梯门开了，你可以走上一块实际上非常、非常、非常、非常、非常高的木板，你往下看，真的很吓人。现在，它绝对会欺骗你的大脑，让你相信自己身处数千英尺的高空走在木板上，如果稍微一倾斜，我就会掉下去并且摔死。这种感觉如此真实，真是太神奇了。所以我们的做法是让参与者走上去，他们可能只迈了一小步。我们问他们，你感觉怎么样？
And we also measured skin conductance response because when you are anxious, you sweat and skin conductance response goes up. And what we found is at the beginning, they were very anxious and they only took a few steps. But over time, people were just jumping off the plank with no anxiety response whatsoever. And what was interesting is that those individuals that habituated faster, so it only took them a few times to like not feel any fear or anxiety at all, we had this questionnaire asking them about risk taking in real life,
我们还测量了皮肤电导反应，因为当你感到焦虑时，你会出汗，皮肤电导反应就会上升。我们发现，在一开始，他们非常焦虑，只迈出了几步。但随着时间的推移，人们竟然毫无焦虑反应地直接从木板上跳了下去。有趣的是，那些习惯化更快的人——也就是说，他们只需要几次尝试就完全感觉不到任何恐惧或焦虑——我们向他们发放了一份问卷，询问他们在现实生活中的冒险行为，
whether it's sports or driving or unsafe sex, and those people who we could measure that their emotional habituation was really fast, right? Those are the people who really took risks in life. So we've looked at the role of habituation when it comes to risk, but that's not the only domain in which we can see habituation when it comes to negative things. You've also looked at habituation when it comes to dishonesty.
无论是运动、开车还是不安全行为，而那些我们能测出其情感习惯化速度非常快的人，对，就是那些真正在生活中冒险的人。我们已经探讨了习惯化在风险方面的作用，但这不是我们能看到对消极事物产生习惯化的唯一领域。你还研究了关于不诚实的习惯化。
Can you tell me how you've designed those studies? What is the setup of those studies? We were interested in whether people habituate to their own lying. Most people think that lying is immoral, right? But if your emotional response will go down over time the more you lie, then you'd probably lie more and more and more. And this is exactly what we tested.
你能讲讲你是如何设计这些研究的吗？这些研究的设置是怎样的？我们对人们是否会对自己的谎言产生习惯化很感兴趣。大多数人认为说谎是不道德的，对吧？但如果你说谎越多，随着时间的推移，你的情绪反应就会下降，那么你可能会越说越多。这正是我们所测试的内容。
So we had people come into the lab and we asked them to play a game. And in this game, they realized that if they lied to the other person they could gain more money at the expense of the other person. And we also recorded their brain activity and what we found that at the beginning they liked but just a little bit maybe a few cents. Next time they had an opportunity maybe a few dollars and the amount by which they lied became bigger and bigger, right? It's like the slippery slope. And at the same time, we looked at activity in their amygdala. So the amygdala is a small part of the brain, and it is important for emotional
所以我们请人们来到实验室，让他们玩一个游戏。在这个游戏中，他们意识到如果他们对另一个人说谎，他们可以以牺牲另一个人的利益为代价获得更多的金钱。我们还记录了他们的大脑活动，我们发现一开始他们会说谎，但可能只说一点点，比如几美分。下一次他们有机会时，可能是几美元，而且他们说谎的金额变得越来越大，对吧？这就像一个滑坡。与此同时，我们观察了他们杏仁核的活动。杏仁核是大脑的一个小部分，对情绪
arousal. And what we found is at the beginning, when people lied, there was a strong emotional response, right? They felt bad about lying. The next time they lied, less of an emotional response. The third time they lied, less. And as the amygdala activity went down, indicating less emotional arousal, people lied more and more and more. That study looks at how we habituate to our own lying, but you also habituate to the lies of other people. If you are in an environment, let's say a work environment, where people are lying, but they start with small lies. You know, maybe they lie a little bit about their expenses, you know, maybe they lie a little bit to the client about what the product can do, and then they lie more and more and more. They start really taking in, you know, thousands of dollars that they shouldn't
唤起很重要。我们发现，在一开始，当人们说谎时，有强烈的情绪反应，对吧？他们对说谎感到内疚。第二次说谎时，情绪反应变小了。第三次说谎时，反应更小了。随着杏仁核活动的下降（表明情绪唤起减少），人们说谎的次数越来越多。那项研究探讨了我们如何对自己的谎言产生习惯化，但你也会对别人的谎言产生习惯化。如果你身处一个环境中，比如一个工作环境，那里的人在说谎，但他们是从小谎开始的。你知道，也许他们在报销费用上撒了一点谎，你知道，也许他们对客户关于产品功能的承诺撒了一点谎，然后他们说谎的次数越来越多。他们开始真正拿走成千上万、本不该属于他们的金钱。
You are more likely to just accept and maybe not even notice if the lies are gradual and We see this in reality when people who have Been quite dishonest Bernie Madoff, for example, they actually tell you about how they started out with small lies and became bigger and bigger. There's a wonderful quote by him. He says, it start out with you taking a little bit, maybe a few hundred, a few thousand, you get comfortable with that and before you know it, it snowballs into something big. And what I like about this
如果谎言是渐进式的，你更有可能只是接受甚至没有注意到，我们在现实中也看到了这一点，比如伯纳德·麦道夫这样相当不诚实的人，他们实际上会告诉你他们是如何从小的谎言开始，然后变得越来越大的。他有一句非常精彩的名言。他说，一开始是你拿了一点，可能几百块，几千块，你对此习以为常，不知不觉中，它就像滚雪球一样变成了大事。我喜欢这句话的地方在于
quote is that he says you get comfortable with that. What this tells me is that he probably felt bad about it when he began, but over time, habituation, he became comfortable. Then he can lie more and more. So along the same lines, Tali, I'm guessing we can also habituate to other problematic things, things like misinformation or pollution or corruption. You know, if these are things that are all around us all the time, after some time it becomes hard to muster a sense of outrage.
他说你对此习以为常。这告诉我说，他刚开始时可能对此感到内疚，但随着时间的推移，通过习惯化，他习惯了。然后他就可以说更多的谎了。因此，顺着同样的思路，塔ali，我猜我们也会对其他有问题的事情产生习惯化，比如错误信息、污染或腐败。你知道，如果这些事情一直环绕在我们身边，一段时间后，我们就会很难激起一种愤慨之情。
Yeah, absolutely. With misinformation actually, there's surveys showing that they ask people, do you think it's okay to kind of fudge a story in order to get more clicks? And the percentage of people who said it's okay to kind of fudge a story in order to get more more clicks and the percentage of people who said it was okay was much smaller about 15 years ago than it is today. So I think with all this kind of like fake news and misinformation online, social media, we started becoming just used to this. We're not as outraged when we learn that someone is changing the story a little bit or maybe just making it up completely.
是的，绝对是这样。实际上，关于错误信息，有调查显示，他们问人们：你认为为了获得更多点击量而稍微篡改一下故事是可以接受的吗？大约15年前，认为稍微篡改故事以获得更多点击量是可以接受的人的比例，比主要今天小得多。所以我认为随着所有这些网络假新闻、错误信息和社交媒体的出现，我们开始变得习以为常了。当我们得知有人稍微改变了故事甚至完全是捏造的时候，我们已经不再那么愤怒了。
It seems that we accept it and we don't have much of an emotional response and probably we don't notice it as much. So, you know, we've looked at sort of many examples of habituation here when it comes to risk, to misinformation, to dishonesty. But at a grander level, I'm also wondering whether it works at the level of societies. When you look at the rise of authoritarian states, for example, sometimes they take away the rights of minorities, but they don't do everything on day one.
似乎我们接受了它，没有太多的情绪反应，可能也没有注意到那么多。所以，你知道，我们在这里看了很多关于习惯化的例子，涉及风险、错误信息、不诚实。但在更宏大的层面上，我也在想这是否也适用于整个社会层面。例如，当你看到威权国家的崛起时，有时他们会剥夺少数群体的权利，但他们不会在第一天就把所有事情都做完。
On day one, it's just a little bit. On day 10, it's a little more. And then by day 500, they've taken away a lot, but by that point, people have become desensitized through the same process of habituation. Right. I think when we look back at the history of humanity, there are all these dark stories of oppression and bloody wars and genocide. And we often look back and we said, how could that be? Right? Why wasn't that stopped earlier? And I think part of the answer is that these extreme political movements and deadly conflicts, they start small and then they increase gradually.
在第一天，只是一点点。在第10天，多了一点。然后到了第500天，他们已经剥夺了很多权利，但到了那个时候，人们通过同样的习惯化过程已经变得麻木了。没错。我想当我们回顾人类历史时，充满了各种压迫、血腥战争和种族灭绝的黑暗故事。我们经常回顾过去并说：怎么会这样呢？为什么没有早点阻止？我想部分答案在于，这些极端的政治运动和致命的冲突都是从小事开始的，然后逐渐升级。
And because they increase very gradually, they end up eliciting a weaker emotional reaction. And because there's less emotional reaction, there's less resistance and more acceptance than there would otherwise be. And we talk about this in our book, and we take Nazi Germany as an example. And there's a lot of testimonies of, for example, German citizens that explain what happened. And when you kind of read those testimonies, they often talk about how things really escalated slowly. Right? People say that each act and each occasion was worse than the last, but only by a little bit. Right?
正因为它们升级得非常缓慢，最终引发的情绪反应也就更弱。正因为情绪反应减少了，抵抗力就会减弱，接受度则会比平时更高。我们在书中也讨论了这一点，并将纳粹德国作为例子。有许多德国公民的证词解释了当时发生的事情。当你阅读这些证词时，他们经常谈到事情是如何真正慢慢升级的。对吧？人们说，每一个行为和每一个事件都比上一次更糟，但也只是一点点而已。对吧？
So we started by Jews are not allowed to be doctors, not allowed to be journalists, and books are burned. And then, you know, there are hundreds and hundreds of steps. And the last one is mass murder, is genocide, right? If the last act was a first act, that would, I believe, would have resulted in much more of a reaction from the people. But it's not. And there's this quote from a German citizen that he says that people could not see it developing from day to day like a farmer in the field that doesn't see the corn growing.
所以我们从犹太人不得担任医生、不得担任记者、书籍被焚烧开始。然后，你知道，有成百上千个步骤。最后一步是大屠杀，是种族灭绝，对吧？如果最后这个行为是第一个行为，我相信这会引发民众更强烈的反应。但事实并非如此。有一位德国公民曾这样说过，人们无法像田里的农夫看不到玉米生长那样，一天天地看出它的发展。
Right? It grows slowly slowly and then one day it's over. There are many other scenarios in which our tendency to habituate to bad things can bring terrible consequences. One example, climate change. Many of the warning signs of climate change are subtle and easy to miss. But even when they are stark and dramatic, think of melting ice caps or raging wildfires or dramatic flooding. Our minds habituate to these phenomena. They become expected, normalized.
对吧？它慢慢地、慢慢地生长，然后有一天它就结束了。还有许多其他场景，我们对坏事的习惯化倾向会带来可怕的后果。一个例子是气候变化。气候变化的许多警告信号都很微妙，很容易被忽视。但即使它们是鲜明而戏剧性的，想想融化的冰盖、肆虐的野火或戏剧性的洪水。我们的大脑也会对这些现象产生习惯化。它们变成了意料之中、习以为常的事情。
Yeah, so the problem here is that first of all, perceptually we habituate, right? When things, let's say pollution, if there's pollution in the air constantly, we kind of get used to it and we don't really notice it's in the air. There's a really interesting survey that shows that in the UK, only 10% of people rate their air quality as poor, despite the fact that pollution breaches legal limits in 88% of UK regions. And then there's also just kind of more of accepting of this idea. Over time, we accept the idea that there's climate change and that there are going to be hurricanes or things like that. And so we have less of a reaction to it. And in fact, that's also been shown nicely on
是的，所以这里的问题首先是我们在感知上产生了习惯化，对吧？当事情发生时，比方说污染，如果空气中一直有污染，我们就会习惯它，并不会真正注意到它就在空气中。有一个非常有趣的调查显示，在英国，只有10%的人认为他们的空气质量很差，尽管事实上英国88%地区的污染都超过了法定标准。然后还有对这种观念的更多接受。随着时间的推移，我们接受了气候变化以及会有飓风之类事情发生的概念。因此，我们对此的反应也变少了。事实上，这一点也在
Twitter. So there's a study where they looked at people, what they said about extreme climate events on Twitter. What they found is that extreme climate events, like hurricanes for example, as they became more and more frequent, people stopped tweeting about it. And on average, it took between two to eight years for people to stop tweeting about climate events, like extreme temperature.
推特上得到了很好的体现。有一项研究观察了人们在推特上关于极端气候事件的言论。他们发现，随着极端气候事件（例如飓风）变得越来越频繁，人们停止了发布相关的推文。平均而言，人们需要两到八年的时间才会停止发布关于极端温度等气候事件的推文。
And if you don't see it and you don't talk about it, then you don't act. So what is the solution for this, Tali? I understand how habituation can work with climate change, but is there a way to fight it? Well, I think the solution here is not to rely on our perception, to rely on instruments. The instruments can tell us quite
如果你看不到它，也不谈论它，你就不会采取行动。那么，对此的解决办法是什么呢，塔ali？我理解习惯化是如何在气候变化中起作用的，但有没有办法对抗它呢？嗯，我认为这里的解决办法是不要依赖我们的感知，而是要依赖仪器。仪器可以很好地告诉我们
well what is happening with the temperature, with climate events, and we should we need to rely on the data, not on our feelings or how we perceive the world to be. It's just not reliable. Because of course I think what you're pointing out is that, you know, our perceptions might habituate to climate change, but our instruments will not, and they will continue to tell us the story. And if we can't trust our own intuitions, what we can trust is the data coming in
温度和气候事件正在发生什么，我们应该、我们需要依靠数据，而不是我们的感觉或我们对世界的感知。这些根本不可靠。因为当然我认为你指出的是，你知道，我们的感知可能会对气候变化产生习惯化，但我们的仪器不会，它们会继续向我们讲述真相。如果我们不能相信自己的直觉，我们可以信任的就是来自
from our instruments. Right, but you know, it's really hard for people to do that. It's really hard for us to say, I'm gonna ignore my perception, I'm gonna rely on the instrument. This is a well-known problem. Often pilots are flying and they can go into vertigo and they feel like they're flying up towards,
我们仪器的源源不断的数据。没错，但你知道，人们要做到这一点真的很难。我们真的很难说：我要忽略我的感知，我要依靠仪器。这是一个众所周知的问题。飞行员在飞行时经常会陷入前庭眩晕，他们会觉得自己正朝着
you know, up in the air, when in fact they're flying down towards the ground. And the instruments show them, you're flying down towards the ground, but they feel like they're flying up. And it's really hard to just say, okay, I'm going to go with the instrument, right? I'm going to fly my plane into what I believe is into the ground because the instrument is telling me, no, this is a way you should do it. And that can lead to accidents and it has led to accidents.
你知道的高空飞去，而事实上他们正在朝地面俯冲。仪器显示他们正在朝地面俯冲，但他们觉得自己在往上飞。要对一个飞行员说“好吧，我要相信仪器，我要把飞机开向我以为是地面的方向，因为仪器告诉我‘不，这才是你该走的路’”，这真的很难。这可能会导致事故，而且过去也确实导致过事故。
I mean, so much of the story is about how our brains have this propensity to forget and ignore and eventually not notice something and how in some ways this can be functional in some elements of our lives. But in other situations, it really is helpful to be able to slow down, to be able to see again. There's not sort of a one size fits all rule when it comes to habituation and dishabituation, is there? Yeah. On one hand, we all want to have that joy again of the things that have been around
我的意思是，这个故事很大程度上关于我们的大脑具有这种容易遗忘、忽视并最终不再注意某事物的倾向，以及这种倾向在某种程度上如何在生活中的某些方面发挥功能。但在其他情况下，能够慢下来、能够重新看清事物确实很有帮助。在习惯化和去习惯化方面，并没有一刀切的规则，对吧？是的。一方面，我们都想重新获得对那些围绕
us for a long time. And we can remember in the past how much joy they had triggered in us, but now we have habituated. So we want to do these things that can maybe cause us to feel more of the happiness and the joy, but also to be able to see things around us, like cracks in our relationships, inefficiencies at work, but also the bigger things, racism and sexism,
我们很长时间的事物的喜悦。我们可以回忆起过去它们曾在我们心中激起多少快乐，但现在我们已经习惯了。所以我们想要做那些或许能让我们感受到更多幸福和快乐的事情，同时也能够看清我们身边的事务，比如我们关系中的裂痕、工作中的低效，以及更大的问题，比如种族主义和性别歧视，
so we can act to change them. Tali Sharad is a cognitive neuroscientist at University College London. Along with Cass Sunstein, she's the author of Look Again, The Power of Noticing What Was Always There. Tali, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. It was a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes,
这样我们才能采取行动去改变它们。塔利·沙里特是伦敦大学学院的认知神经科学家。她与凯斯·桑斯坦合著了《再看一眼：注意到一直都在的力量》。塔利，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。非常荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、
Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hiddenbrains executive editor. Over the past year we've heard from many listeners who asked if we had plans to make our podcast subscription, Hiddenbrain Plus, available for users of Android phones. We're so pleased to share that Hiddenbrain Plus is now available across platforms and devices. You can sign up via our Patreon page, just go to support.hiddenbrain.org. That site again is support.hiddenbrain.org. Of course, you can still find us on Apple Podcasts by searching for Hidden Brain and
安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔担任我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。过去一年里，我们听到许多听众询问我们是否有计划为安卓手机用户推出播客订阅服务“隐藏的大脑Plus”。我们非常高兴地与大家分享，“隐藏的大脑Plus”现已在各大平台和设备上推出。您可以通过我们的Patreon页面注册，只需访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。网址再次是 support.hiddenbrain.org。当然，您仍然可以在Apple Podcasts上搜索Hidden Brain并
clicking the Try Free button or by going to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. No matter which option you choose, your subscription provides key support to help us build you many more episodes of Hidden Brain. We're truly grateful. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
点击“免费试用”按钮，或者访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain 来找到我们。无论您选择哪个选项，您的订阅都为我们继续为您制作更多集的《隐藏的大脑》提供了关键支持。我们对此由衷感激。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。